[Musique]
ce soir la rue hamelin la possession la
sa tranquillité sont cannes pour une
soirée festive
ambiance décontractée pour ses invités
qui se prépare pour la fête des voisins
la rue chopin c'est la première fois
qu'ils viennent on va bien les chambres
et les choses comme il faut après groupe
donc après ben il y aura le repas du
matin 150 habitants du quartier sont
attendus ce soir chacun participe à
l'organisation en apportant un plat ou
une boisson
l'objectif c'est de faire la fête et de
nouer des liens avec son voisinage sud
et à son bateau bonsoir
enfin quand vous voyez c'est festif il
ya de l'entente et à l'amusement
il faut une pas hésité à se lancer parce
que c'est vrai qu'il serait difficile à
mettre en place mais si tout le monde
joue le jeu ben c'est comme ça ce soir
moment de convivialité et un moment de
remonter des changes
parce que tout le monde y amène chacun
un petit quelque chose et c'est le
battage le tout le monde mais en somme
ce qu'il ce qu'il a de mieux et moi j'ai
envie de dire que c'est cela aussi la
réunion
le mieux vivre ensemble que je prône
c'est cela et la fête des voisins est un
beau symbole de notre vivre ensemble à
la réunion
c'est la sixième année consécutive que
ces riverains se retrouvent pour
partager ce moment fait
le rendez vous est déjà pris pour
l'année prochaine
[Musique]